it's fine it's fine [ __ ] I feel like
everyone secretly loves a good selfie
Beyonce stylist recently released an LED
phone case that's supposed to help you
achieve a flawless selfie we're going to
try it out today and see if we can look
like Beyonce
it's ladylike and today we're testing
out the tie light I used to think that
selfies were dumb but now I kind of get
it I have grown to love and respect
selfies
I feel like selfies get such a bad rap
like anyone taking a selfie is
considered narcissistic or super into
themselves if I read one more salty
think piece in like some old-ass
magazine about why selfies are like
ruining the Millennial Generation I'm
going to lose my mind
I think it's cool that people feel
confident enough to be like Here I am
here's my look I feel cute like hello
world if you're comfortable with posting
selfies I say go for it
ah this is it I like how it says tilite
with four exclamation marks over it
highlight oh it has three different
color temperatures oh whoa the back is
hard but the side is like soft and jelly
this is like a powered tool this looks
like something I would pick up at Home
Depot not something that I would just
like throw on my phone if I'm going for
a night out oh [ __ ] OOP whew this is
just a flashlight this is just like I
lost my keys okay that's really cool hmm
like it's definitely a flattering light
I don't exactly know how I feel about
using this in a dark environment I'm
sure everyone would stare at me and see
that I'm using this tie light and trying
to take selfies I think this is gonna be
like this selfie stick how it started
out as a joke and everyone thought it
was dumb but now people realize how
useful it actually is I feel like the
biggest test will be how it works at
night let's [ __ ] do it
it's ladylike
I'm gonna see what this phone case is
really made of so it's late at the
office which is probably actually a
prime so I'll be taking time for me
because I get really bored I'm outside
this restaurant it's very dark
definitely looks better it's like really
good for evening in the night like I can
see every crevice of my face this is on
you're supposed to use for indoor I
think this makes me look very orange see
how shiny and the final setting which is
a mix of hot and cold lights you know
very good for people like needs I think
that outside lighting like the cool
lighting is the best one I prefer my
camera's own flash I feel like it looks
too manufactured if you're in a place
where you don't need as much
harsh so what I've learned using the tie
light it makes your teeth amazing if you
wear glasses trying throw on those
contacts where night out highlight
theirs
okay so we figured out how to adjust the
brightness which changes the game a lot
if you guys hold the button down so now
I like it yeah it took us like 48 hours
to figure that out it was great though
the tie line was fun good for selfish
yeah I'm still pretty into selfies too
this is just another tool to enhance
them you can take selfies alone at your
desks like kind of sly but if you have
this like you people will know yeah
people will know I mean it's don't be
blatant about yourself love yeah thank
you did yeah also Tyree Rams me and
Freddie's so we like ty hey